[Music]
welcome to this video where we'll
discuss how you can manage your teams
within a fleet we look at a team
management feature called Scopes and
explain how you can use Scopes so that
your teams can access the Clusters they
need to run their workloads before we
continue you'll need to be familiar with
the concepts of fleets and namespaces
just to recap fleets are a way to
logically group kubernetes clusters for
easier management
whether those clusters are on Google
cloud on-premises or other public Cloud
environments
fleets help you manage your
multi-cluster deployments but what if
you have several teams that need to
access different clusters on your Fleet
how do you organize your teams and
clusters so that they don't interfere
with each other's workloads
for example maybe the web server team
only needs access to clusters A and B
while the database management team needs
to run workloads on all clusters within
your Fleet
you need a way to provision and manage
access to these clusters depending on
your team's requirements
that's where team management comes in
Team Management features give you an
additional level of organization within
your Fleet so you can Define which
clusters are accessible to a team
these definitions are called scopes
a scope is just a grouping of Fleet
clusters that you can use for different
purposes
you can include just one cluster in a
scope or you could have several
you just need to ensure that all
clusters within a scope belong to the
same Fleet
so the first step is to create a scope
where you'll identify which clusters you
want in that scope
then for Team Management purposes within
each scope you'll create one or more
Fleet namespaces this is just like a
kubernetes namespace except that it's
created inside a scope
team members will then be given access
to the scope so that they can run their
workloads on those clusters within that
scope going back to our earlier example
since the web server team needs to run
workloads on clusters A and B
you would create a team scope that
includes these two clusters only
since the database management team needs
access to all the Clusters in this Fleet
you would create a second scope that
includes all the fleet clusters
as you can see here the same cluster can
belong to more than one scope so
different teams can run workloads on the
same cluster
the next step in this process is to
create Fleet namespaces in the scope
just like other kubernetes namespaces a
fleet namespace provides isolation of
resources between teams teams can use
this namespace just like any other
kubernetes namespace
the final step is to give teams access
to the Clusters in their scope
once teams have access they can then use
their namespace to run workloads in
their clusters in this video we've seen
how you can group your Fleet clusters
into scopes you can use scopes for
several purposes but here we looked
specifically at how Scopes can help you
manage and organize your infrastructure
resources for teams
to learn more about fleet team
management check out our documentation
thanks for watching
[Music]
foreign